[Applaudissements]
trois photos du projet paris saclay 2025
d illustration de ce que serait le
village global lors de l'exposition
universelle
l'agglomération s'est lancé depuis trois
ans pour représenter la france et
accueillir l'événement mondial en 2025
un projet soutenu aussi par les
habitants du territoire alors justement
j'ai pris en photo parce que je trouve
que les images sont très belles et donne
très envie d'avoir cette expo
universelle c'est important parce que
finalement c'est la concrétisation
universel du gloucester est en cours sur
ce territoire qu'on a aujourd'hui les
infrastructures qui vont se développer
notamment le grand paris express
on allait nice universités qui sont déjà
présentes on a un cadre environnemental
qui est magnifique avec la vallée de
chevreuse donc je pense qu'on a les
atouts et je pense que ce serait bien
pour l'économie pour le développement
social culturel de la région
le président du conseil départemental de
l'essonne françois durovray et michel
bournat président de la communauté
d'agglomération paris saclay ont réussi
à fédérer les collectivités locales
autour du projet notamment les communes
dorcé de gif sur yvette et même au delà
du département près de 60 millions de
visiteurs sont attendus sur le village
global
nous avons les établissements
d'enseignement supérieur de recherche
nous avons des sites exceptionnels de
techno château de versailles
et quand on additionne ces éléments
académiques culturels économiques
on s'inscrit parfaitement dans les
logiques qui sont mises en avant pour
une exposition universelle
plusieurs sites sont dans la course face
à paris saclay gonesse marne-la-vallée
ou encore la vallée de l'ourcq
le dépôt des dossiers est prévue le 19
mai le territoire d'accueil du village
global en france sera connu le 25 juin
prochain pour un choix final entre la
france et le japon en novembre 2018
[Musique]